job of waiting you can see right away he
sees to play he recovers hose off
Tristan Thompson and gets to play and
Kauai just uses the right shoulder
[Music]
Leonard for three
tell you what we struggled for about
seven games and now he's found the range
again he's four or five from distance
lop the Thompson great defense by zoos
the Clippers have time Kauai is away he
made the steal he saw the clock and he
battled through the traffic he used his
strength all these two defenders it's a
precious commodity you can't just go
around him through there just throw it
away
Kauai fadeaway spicy and he used to quit
dribble and he saw right away that
Tristan Thompson wanted to try to stop
the basketball and as a player you just
want to throw the basketball right here
the quick jab Brandon Knight from the
initial possession lost his footing and
Kawhi Leonard calibrated that move
because of shot 55% on the floor there
haven't been a lot of rebounds available
all this
three 40:24 kawaii